The vertex shader only knows about a single vertex at a time. It normally
doesn't know about the whole triangle. So this statement is false. The vertex
shader is given just one vertex at a time, so has only its position. The second
statement is true. The vertex shader can output the shading normal, which is
then interpolated across the triangle's surface. The fragment shader will
probably want to normalize the shading normal before using it. The third
statement is also true. Even though the vertex itself does not have a color
stored in it, the vertex shader can compute and output anything it wants. Even
though we call the outputs things like position, normal, color and so on, as
far as the GPU is concerned, it's all just data to interpolate. The fourth
statement is false for the same reason the first is false. Each vertex is
processed separately by the vertex shader, so data from a specific vertex
cannot be passed to the fragment shader in this way. You could work around this
limitation by doing expensive things like storing the data for all three
verticies at every vertex and have the vertex shader sort it out. A better
solution is to use the geometry shader if available. Currently it's not
supported by WebGL. How many times have I said this? But I really do expect
this will change in the future. When available, the geometry shader is optional
and is applied after the vertex shader. It allows you to access the data for
the triangle as a whole. You can in fact use the geometry shader to create new
points, lines and triangles.